hello welcome to our daily homeroom
livestream for those of y'all that this
is your first time coming this is
something that we started doing when we
started seeing school closures around
the world Khan Academy we are
not-for-profit with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and so obviously a
big part of that is we've been creating
learning materials software videos all
free all not commercial and as soon as
we saw the school closures happening we
said we have to make this as usable as
possible for teachers parents and
students so that everyone can keep
learning so that's when we started
publishing schedules putting out
learning plans parent and teacher
webinars and we also thought in a time
of social distancing would it be nice if
there was a place where we could connect
in a I guess you could say synchronous
way well we could talk to have
conversations answer each other's
questions bring on interesting guests
and that's what this livestream is for
now before we get into the meat of the
livestream and today's the meat of
today's livestream will be around
givingtuesday there's actually a lot of
things going on it's national teachers
of teacher appreciation week we'll talk
a little bit about that but it's also
giving Tuesday but in line with giving
Tuesday I do want to remind everyone
again we are not-for-profit and the only
way we're able to do our work for it to
be free for it to be non-commercial a
lot of people come to Khan Academy and
they think there's a catch there's like
clearly there's a lot of resources being
put into it are they going to try to
sell me something at some point the
reason why we don't and we never intend
to is because we're supported with
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself and we'll talk a lot about that
over the course of today's conversation
but I do want to give special thanks to
several corporations that have stepped
up in recent weeks when they found out
that we were already running at a
deficit before the kovat crisis and now
in the crisis with our traffic being 2
to 3 x of what it typically is and we're
trying to accelerate all of these
programs to figure out better ways to
support parents teachers and students
Bank for America google.org 18 teen
Novartis and fast C all stepped up
literally in a matter of days to make
sure that we have less of a gap
but we still need more help I want to
make it very clear Khan Academy is much
more than just me there's 200 full-time
teachers researchers engineers designers
managers who are bringing Khan Academy
to you and because of that we're able to
serve we have over a hundred million
registered users there's tens of
millions of learners who come on a
monthly basis and that's only possible
with financial support donations so
given that today is giving Tuesday
that's going to be the focus of this but
this will be a two-way exchange I am
going to try to convince you if you're
in a position I don't want to guilt you
if you're not in a position to do so but
every dollar matters but if you're in a
position to do so please think about
donating and in return one well the main
thing in return of all of us at Khan
Academy we're going to be able to do our
work and hopefully serve you and many
millions of students around the world
but I'm also happy to answer any
questions that you might have about
anything so this is a true ask me
anything and so whether you're watching
on Facebook or on YouTube put your
questions in the message boards myself
and some team members we're going to be
looking at it and as long as it's decent
as nothing is out of bounds I'm happy to
answer any any question so you know
while we're waiting for for questions to
come in I'm just going to you know we
have some goals with our team we're
hoping to get 20,000 donations
you know we care about the number of
people donating because that shows that
hey there's other people in this boat
with us there's other people around the
world who care about this mission of
free world-class education for anyone
anywhere even if they're donating $3
that makes a difference and it's a huge
show of support for the work that we're
doing our goal is to raise fifty
thousand dollars on YouTube in the month
of May and twenty-five thousand dollars
on Facebook in this week if you look I
believe it's on my left
I think I'm pointing in the right place
you will see donate buttons either on
Facebook or YouTube where you'll have an
opportunity to donate once again if
you're in a position to do so please
think about doing that and I will you
know read some quick testimonials just
to get a sense of a flavor of how people
are using Khan Academy right
and this is the type of thing that gives
us energy and I hope all of y'all
if you view yourself as part of the Khan
Academy community which I hope you do
especially if you're a supporter then
you take satisfaction and things like
this this is a thing we got recently
from this is we got this year's a quote
from a physician actually I'm a resident
physician in New York we've been working
long hard days with Kovac patients I'm
writing to say thank you I used your
materials early
I used your early materials to get
through my undergraduate and medical
education my two-and-a-half year old has
been home due to school closures and I
haven't had a chance to see her much in
the past last few weeks I came home
today and she said let's sing the Khan
Academy song in regards to a song that
has helped her learn to count your
educational programs carried me through
my education and are now teaching my
young daughter thank you that's John and
so first of all John if you're listening
or maybe you'll watch the recording of
this later thank you so much for that
one the work you're doing the medical
workers are genuinely on the front line
of this war whatever you want to call it
against kovat so thank you for doing
that work and it makes us incredibly
happy and incredibly proud that not only
were we able to be part of your
education so in our way by us helping
you many years ago maybe you're you're
going to be able to help that many more
people with kovat but also in this time
of need and I'm sure your family needs
support and your family's going through
a lot of stress it's our honor to be
able to support your daughter through
her learning and for those of you who
don't know Khan Academy kids I had
Caroline over who's the founder of Khan
Academy kids last Friday on the
livestream I can't speak highly enough
how cool it is I have a five and a half
year old they just added first grade
content they also just added teacher
tools so teachers can make assignments
and see what students have completed and
it starts as early as ages two it goes
up to ages seven and I really think that
that is it's in math reading writing
social-emotional learning and you even
have stuff on on logic it covers all of
the standards that can be covered in
that format I encourage parents or
anyone in your family who might have an
early learner to check that out and
that's the type of work that we're able
to do with this support
and this all costs resources and whether
it's the court Khan Academy that many of
y'all are familiar with or kind of kind
of me get out kit kind of CAD me kids
it's your donations that allow us to
build that support that support tens of
millions of users every month and to
continue to improve on improve on that
so let's see we have questions we have
questions here so one from Instagram
Sarah helis Lee sleepy I think that's an
interest
what motivated you to build Khan Academy
so I've told the story a little bit but
I'll tell it again in a fast form I was
tutoring cousins back in 2004 my day job
I was an analyst at an investment firm
and I just saw that maybe there was some
tools that I could help build that'll
help my family so that's where I started
writing the exercise platform a very
early version of it for my cousin's to
get practice feedback for me as their
teacher or their tutor to keep track of
what they were doing and then a few
years later a friend suggested hey why
don't you make video lessons to
supplement this software thing you're
making and I thought it was a horrible
idea
cats playing piano it's YouTube it's not
for serious math but I got over the idea
it wasn't my idea and I gave it a shot
and long story short I made it for my
family but it soon became clear that
people who are not my family were
watching and by 2008 I said this could
be a real thing and that's why I
incorporated Khan Academy as a
not-for-profit and for those of you who
don't know what a not-for-profit is it
means no one owns Khan Academy it is a
public charity
I do not own Khan Academy another way to
think about it you own as much of Khan
Academy as I do I do get a salary from
Khan Academy all of our team members get
salaries from Khan Academy but we are
employees of this organization it's
governed by a board and that board it's
you know in a for-profit organization
the board is how do we maximize
shareholder value and a not-for-profit
board the board says how do we maximize
impact especially impact aligned with
our mission which is a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and by
2009 you know I was hoping at first to
set up as a not-for-profit maybe some
friends would volunteer to help me out
but by 2009 I had trouble focusing on my
day job
and I saw you know my first child was
just born my wife was a medical resident
so we were making a little bit of money
but I decided to quit my job and we
lived off the savings we're digging into
our savings about $5,000 a month just
under the belief that this needed to
exist in the world at back then there
was about a hundred thousand people
using Khan Academy on a monthly basis
and I used to say who knows maybe one
day would be a million ten million a
hundred million and at the time it
they'll seem like delusional ideas but
those are now true and I think the
opportunity and I said maybe one day
billions I could learn from this and
imagine if future generations they don't
view education as something that only
the affluent have or only certain people
have but they say as long as I have at
least a low-cost smartphone I can have
access to the world's best material I
have practice and feedback and
eventually and I can learn everything
from early learning in math reading
writing all the way through the core of
elementary middle high school college
not just in math not just in ela but the
social sciences the sciences and
eventually plug it into the world
imagine if we could create a world like
that and so that was the hope of Khan
Academy that's why it was a
not-for-profit and that's why I hope
that you're also excited about that type
of a vision of what we could do for the
world together I hope one day all of you
are able to tell your children or your
grandchildren yeah there was a time
where free world-class education wasn't
a thing that what zip code you were born
in how much your family made that was
the biggest predictor of what you're
going to do in your life which
unfortunately it is the case right now
but we think we can change that and
empower everyone and that not only level
the playing field but think about how
many how many Marie Curie's or Albert
Einstein's for every one that we
discover how many go undiscovered think
about all of the work that those kids
who might be living in a slum someplace
in India right now if they're able to
tap into their potential what they might
be able to do for us they might find the
vaccine for the next pandemic a cure for
a disease write the next great novel a
solve existential problems for humanity
so that's that's kind of the dream of
Khan Academy and how I how I got started
so let's see we got we have
more we have more questions here so from
Instagram at Sarah girl 20/20 saying I'm
having trouble staying focused on my
online classes how can I be a little bit
better
good question Sarah so I'll tell you
well there's a couple of things that
I've been doing one is I love to keep
moving so you could imagine I said in a
lot of meetings these days and now
they're all over zoom and Google meat
whatever else so what I've been doing is
actually I've been doing them wild
walking and you'll be surprised I'm
surprised you know you can be on a phone
and look in a zoo meeting and you can
still see the screen and see what's
going on but I find if I'm just in a
park ideally you're in someplace where
there's not any traffic so you can't get
hit by a car but I go to my local park
and I just keep doing laps while I'm in
the meeting and I find that that helps
me stay focused it gives me exercise I
get fresh air which is especially
important in this time of social
distancing so if you're lucky enough to
have a safe environment to walk in I
think that's another thing I think you
know I would I think a lot of educators
are trying to figure things out right
now so I think if you give constructive
feedback saying hey teacher that was a
great session I really appreciate it but
I would love to see even a more
interactivity I would love a ways if
there's ways that we can participate you
can ask us questions I think a lot of
educators would welcome that they want
they want you to participate more so
that's another way to stay really
engaged in general whether it's online
or offline or just work you have to do
there's something called the Pomodoro
Technique which we've talked about
before it's named after a Pomodoro is a
type of tomato but it's named after a
timer that was shaped like a Pomodoro
tomato and the general idea is you give
yourself 20 minutes 30 minutes you put
it on the timer and you say okay over
that time I'm gonna work on whatever it
is and then when that timer rings you
give yourself a ten minute break at ten
minutes to take a walk do some jumping
jacks dance a little bit whatever and
then get back to work and by doing it in
those sessions you might think that 10
minutes is kind of a waste of time where
you're taking a break but it's not
you're rejuvenating and then it'll give
you more energy to then focus and go
deep on whatever you're trying to work
on so more testimonials and I actually
want to give a shout out to thank yous
on several of the donation
Eliott H thank you so on YouTube thank
you so much for your donation
so Ethel if I'm reading your user name
correctly thank you so much just rated
$100 on YouTube thank you so much
Whittle and shuttle writes Thank You Sal
and everyone at Khan Academy is the
noble cause the more knowledge we all
have the more humane we become and I
perrantes if I'm not pronouncing your
name correctly your user name SJ ethyl
or Shweta l' couldn't agree with you
more and I will emphasize I get a
disproportionate amount of credit for
Khan Academy there's 200 plus full-time
folks about five or six seven somewhere
actually behind the scenes right now
supporting supporting this this
livestream and beyond that we have
thousands of volunteers around the world
and that that show of confidence through
that donation makes a huge difference
and that donation is going to make a
huge difference there's this framework
that this foundation Robin Hood
Foundation which focuses on New York but
it's a framework that they came up with
for calculating something called social
benefit to cost ratio and it's a way you
know in the for-profit world you look at
something called return on investment
where you say hey if I invest $100 and I
get $30 more and I get my hundred
dollars back that's a 30% return on
investment and so in my hedge fund world
we're all with you know back in the
hedge fund days I would always think
well okay where we gonna get the best
financial return
well the not-for-profit world where you
gonna get the best impact return how
much impact for your dollar and it's
it's generally good if you're able to
get even a two to one impact $2 ratio so
there's a social impact of two and you
say how do you measure social impact
well you could say well if someone's
able to improve their academic standing
by X amount how will that effect their
lifetime earnings how much will that
decrease cost in other parts of society
you know education is inversely
correlated with how much if imprisoned
people and crime and all of these other
things and and and then there's tax
revenues that you get the more educated
people get and so using proxies like
that a very good social return is about
a 10 to 1 social benefit to cost ratio
is 10 to 1 is is a great one if you look
at Khan Academy and there's actually
video I'm happy to share it but it's a
video where I do that
back-of-the-envelope calculation you'll
see Khan Academy you get someplace
between actually priek Ovid someplace
between a 250 to 400 to 1 ratio and post
kovat now that our usage is about 200 to
X 3 X of what it typically is those
numbers go up by 2 3 X so you're talking
about in a world where a good social
benefit to cost ratio is 2 to 1 3 to 1
we're talking about a social benefit to
cost ratio which is like 500 to 1 so for
anyone donating even that dollar you
should feel very good about that
even that $1 that's going to drive
learning for someone on the planet
probably someone who wouldn't who
doesn't have $1 to learn for a good
amount of time I the numbers correctly
our cost of driver delivering learning
is around 15 cents per hour
so even that dollar is able to impact a
lot of people that hundred dollars that
you gave show Ethel there's going to be
a lot of people that are going to be
empowered because of that so thank you
so much for it so I have a more
testimonials here so this is from a
Heather who's a parent Heather writes
I've been using Khan Academy for six of
my children since the onset of Kovan 19
since the onset of Kovan 19 pandemic I
would have used it sooner had I known it
was available free of charge please
donate if you can it's truly beneficial
to families especially now well thank
you Heather and we agree with you one
other thing is that you know donate that
would be huge and hopefully you feel
yourself as part of this mission and
part of this community for anyone out
there make sure that there's other
parents like Heather who could benefit
from this and their children could
benefit but there's still an awful lot
of people who don't know about Khan
Academy or maybe they heard about Khan
Academy and they think we're a
for-profit organization they say oh
that's just another one of those EdTech
companies that's trying to get me on
some $5 a month plan or something like
that that is not who we are we are there
to give you free access to what we
genuinely believe are the best materials
out there
one of the logical fallacies or
emotional fallacies we sometimes see is
people think they get something better
when they pay for it
and sometimes some of these for-profit
companies are able to take advantage of
that they're like Oh Khan Academy is
free but we charge you 10 dollars a
month so you must think it's better but
do your research the number of efficacy
studies done on chronic
the level of transparency our ability to
partner with folks like the College
Board around the SAT if you objectively
ask knowledgeable people in the field
compared the Khan Academy resources
side-by-side with any of the things even
some of these things cost hundreds of
dollars a year I think you'll find that
the Khan Academy resources are deeper
more aligned with learning science have
much more efficacy research on it you
know look at the Khan Academy kids
material it's free it's not commercial I
challenge anyone to find anything that
costs money that comes close to what the
team kind of Kadim kids and I brag about
them a little bit more because you know
I can't claim that I did that other than
you know they kind of joined forces with
us and I obviously help fundraise for
them and make sure that we're aligned
from a pedagogical and strategy point of
view but they've been doing incredible
stuff and obviously on the Khan Academy
the core Khan Academy where I am more
involved and many many other people are
involved I can't tell you how much work
is put in to make sure it's aligned with
learning science make sure it's aligned
to standards and then do efficacy
research on it and make sure we're
impacting as many students as possible
so more questions from from AMA
questions ask me anything questions from
YouTube Matias Yamoto says and I'm
reading these you know so I don't know
what this is about to say so I'm just
gonna hi Sal I want to thank you and and
the board for bringing Khan Academy to
Brazil can you explain why you guys
selected our country and your
expectations for the future so great
question Matias so it's interesting in
the early days of Khan Academy obviously
we've always had this mission statement
free world-class education for anyone
anywhere and part of that vision is we
want to make this available to everyone
on the planet localized not just the
videos but the software platform the
teacher tools and that what you know
when we got our first funding in 2010 it
was from the Gates Foundation and Google
org and the Google aspect of the funds
they said they want they wanted us to
start translating this into the language
of the world so that's what we started
back in 2010 and then I believe it was
2012 we had this gentleman visit our
offices out here in Mountain View from
Brazil named bought by the name of
George Apollo lemon and you know our
offices even now our offices aren't
fancy by any stretch of the imagination
but back then my office was above a
tea shop in downtown Mountain View and
it was kind of you know one of our first
funders walked in it's a salad this is
not a this is not a healthy working
environment and so she she sent some
painters and handyman to just make it a
vaguely decent environment but George
Apollo visited that office and you you
know if you're from Brazil you might
have heard of George Apollo III I'm
ashamed to say that I didn't know about
George Apollo but he's actually one of
the biggest philanthropist in Brazil and
he and his team came and said we need to
bring Khan Academy to Brazil as soon as
possible and we were like a five person
organization at the time they were like
oh well we don't know how we're gonna be
able to do that and they're like well we
can support Khan Academy we can help
support the efforts in Brazil and so the
lemon foundation named after George
Apollo lemon
they helped support Khan Academy proper
and so they've since then been great
donors and supporters of us but they've
also we've been able to partner with
them in Brazil to align our to localize
the work into Brazilian Portuguese align
it with the Brazilian national Common
Core do efficacy in research studies in
Brazilian schools there was even a soap
opera episode in Brazil I heard where
the protagonist I ran a fundraiser for
Khan Academy so we have a lot of good
connections to Brazil I visited there
and I had a wonderful time I actually
brought my whole family there and and
and worked with the lemon folks so
that's what really pulled us in to
Brazil so we have 45 translation
projects around the world most of its
volunteers who are able to do it in
their own languages and their unpaid and
we and your donations are allowing us to
build a platform so that they can do it
but there's several geographies that
were able to go deeper Brazil is one of
them
India's and other and then
spanish-speaking Latin America
especially places like Peru and Mexico
we have partners Carlos Slim Foundation
in Mexico and Carlos Rodriguez pastor
and his foundation in Peru and Tata
trust in India these are all foundations
that have allowed us to go deeper but I
do want to make it clear we are all of
these groups have each been donating a
lot of resources to make this happen but
for all of us to reach literally the
hundreds of millions of billions we need
more resources and so it's it's a real
partnership with both large philanthropy
and foundations and
small philanthropists oh and people who
can give even that $20 at $10 or even
even those $3 it all makes a huge
difference so a question from youtube
emanuel so its asks how important do you
think coding will be for children's
education in the future so I'm a big
coding fan my background my undergrad I
was a computer science major I always
got a lot of joy out of coding coding
empowered me to build the first versions
of Khan Academy kind of Kennedy wouldn't
exist if I didn't have some of those
early desires to prototype with coding
and so I view it as it can be a very
very valuable skill that's why we've
invested on Khan Academy on our coding
platform we're kids and I encourage
anyone anyone who thinks that coding is
not for them go to Khan Academy and try
our coding platform you're going to see
that it focuses on the creative side of
coding you get to make pictures and
animations literally within minutes but
it takes you all the way down the path
so that you meet you can actually
understand fairly sophisticated ideas in
computer programming and computer
science and so I think there's two
tracks I think there's a lot of you know
the need for software engineers computer
programmers it's only going to increase
there's so many industries that are
going to be are going to leverage things
like computing and data analytics and
data science and artificial intelligence
more than they are today
and so there's just going to be more and
more and more jobs there so it's
valuable for that but even if someone
isn't going to become a computer
programmer if you're going to become a
doctor if you're gonna become a lawyer
whatever feel accountant whatever field
someone goes in almost every one of
those industries are going to be
affected by computing going forward and
so it's valuable to have at least a
baseline understanding of what computers
can do how computing logic works so that
you can navigate whatever field you go
into in the future I'll also add that
you know the what's fun about
programming and computing is it helps
build a certain form of critical
thinking and logic which is I think
valuable in every field so a big picture
you know I'm still a big you know you're
reading you're reading you're three
hours so to speak which were never ours
three hours two hours and an a a reading
riting and rithmetic those are always
going to be super core and there's
be super core for the 21st century and
but you know I think computing builds a
lot of those same skills that the
mathematics does in terms of the
critical thinking and and there's a
whole there's of it there's a creation
side to it too in this engineering side
which is super valuable so if kids can
get exposed to it I would love to see it
and that's why we we have that on Khan
Academy we also have APCs principals
which is an Advanced Placement course
which is designed to be broad so that a
lot of people might want to take it so
you could go on Khan Academy right now
and are you could either learn to
program on our coding platform or go to
APCs principles and I think almost
anyone watching this could engage on it
and it not only does it do the basics of
coding it is how do computers work how
does the internet work what is internet
security all of these things you are
always hearing about we make available
on on Khan Academy so I definitely
recommend taking a look at some of that
work as well so let's see there's a
question there's a testimonial from AJ
who's a student so AJ wrote to us and
says no joke the only reason I graduated
college was because of Khan Academy I
pledge to myself that if I graduated I
would give every year after I graduated
I have kept that promise and I am giving
a little bit more during the kovat
pandemic because I want to make sure
that everyone has the opportunity to
learn well AJ thank you so much that
means a ton to us I know especially for
a young professional you're out of
college you probably don't have a lot of
money but whatever you can donate makes
a big difference you know makes a
difference on two levels though the
money obviously allows us to do work
allows us to hire people pay our server
costs our server costs our loan or
several million dollars a year but also
just that show of confidence you know I
can't tell you you know that positive
energy that you send our way by
supporting this makes a big difference
to us as well it energizes me and I know
it energizes the team and it's it's a
very powerful example for hopefully
other people to help donate to this this
cause that I that we think can can
empower billions of folks over
generations so from YouTube life an ask
Sal if you have 1 million dollars what
will you do with it and I'm assuming the
question is if Khan Academy had a
million dollar
if I had a million dollars I might think
about donating it to Khan Academy
you know I'll answer your question I'll
go on a little tangent a lot of people
said Sal how come Khan Academy isn't a
for-profit company and you know I went
through that thought process in the
early days cuz before I actually even
talk to any philanthropist I live in the
middle of Silicon Valley some of my
friends are venture capitalists they
offered hey I'll write $100,000 check
right now you give me X percent and then
you can quit your day job and we can
turn Khan Academy into the next
billion-dollar company and so you can
imagine that was very tempting but you
know what I went through the thought
process I was getting so much psychic
reward from folks like AJ saying how it
helped them and I said well what if I
what if we get to put a paywall behind
it or what if when someone wants to
learn algebra they have to watch an ad
and there's something that just doesn't
feel good about it and I imagine what a
homerun would look like in the
for-profit world if it's a homerun it
would be a Google or a Facebook or an
apple and that's great I think all three
of those organizations do amazing work
they all innovate in the world and
amazing ways but then I thought what
would a homerun be in the not-for-profit
world
well what if Khan Academy could be that
next great institution like the
Smithsonian or the Library System or the
great universities and it can it could
be accessible by literally billions of
people that you know I thought about you
know I when I started this I didn't have
kids now I have three kids but I thought
about my grandkids and their kids what
would they be more proud of Khan Academy
and what and what could keep Khan
Academy sticking to its vision in its
mission and in my old career as a hedge
fund analyst I saw how much the actions
of a company are dictated by who owns
the company that you could have a
founder who wants to do very altruistic
things but as soon as the ownership
changes it might go in a completely
different way especially if it's owned
by you know firms that are just out
there to maximize the the buck and so I
said okay if I want Khan Academy to last
multiple generations uh and and stay
true to that mission and that mission is
it's true bottom line it's got to be a
not-for-profit and I went through the
thought process even if I were to start
the next Google and become a billionaire
I would just want to donate that money
to to the effort of Education anyway so
let me just cut out the middleman and
and you know as the benefit of a
non-for-profit is it it's any any excess
we don't have any right now but if we
were able to not run into deficit it's
not taxed and would it would go towards
a reserve and so I said well why just
cut to the chase let me just you know if
I can make a decent living as a
professor and I have to say Khan
Academy's board pays me more than
generously I feel like I'm the luckiest
person on the planet that I get to be
paid to do what I love you know anything
above what I need for that
you know what those billions that could
have been I'm much happier that we're
able to create an organization that has
impact for the broader world and I know
many of the employees of Khan Academy
many of them are supporting this they
could go you know Google is in the same
town as we are Facebook is down the
street Apple is a couple of miles away
pretty much all of them if they were
just optimizing for money could go to
those places and get stock and and and
probably double you know their total
comp or whatever we're looking at but
they've all made the decision that they
they want to work on this mission so in
a lot of ways they're also major donors
to this organization and so anyway that
was me going on a tangent but that's
where I you know I obviously feel quite
passionately about the world needs
something like this and I can't imagine
something more I don't I don't
there's I I can't imagine being luckier
than to be able to work on a mission
like this and now if the question is
what would Khan Academy do with that
incremental million dollars it is you
know we want to make sure that our
servers stay performant that when you go
there you know it doesn't take seconds
to load up that it's a fast great
experience we're always looking at how
do we improve the user experience for
this coming back to school we're looking
at ways to maybe do some quick
diagnostics and ways for students to
build their foundations quickly because
we know with a lot of kids out of school
they're going to have a huge variance in
preparedness we would as you know every
dollar much less every million dollars
allows us to think about adding more
subject areas or improving the subject
areas that we already have so those are
just a sample of the things that we
would do with every incremental million
dollars so more donors I just want to
thank so so there's three people donated
anonymously at $140 so thank you
three anonymous people you know who you
are and thank you for that Petco karamo
czev donated on Facebook thank you so
much Petco sathi Mehta on Facebook wrote
thank you for making this available it's
amazing and my eight-year-old loves it
well until your 8 year old to keep going
and thank you sake for the for that
donation from YouTube
Michelle Polly Aloha I'm assuming you're
in you're in Hawaii just donated on your
website thank you so much I am a teacher
and use it religiously for students and
myself well Michelle two things thank
you for donation and this I would say
this no matter what because I love the
work I mean the work that educators do
is the ultimate work but especially
given this is teacher appreciation week
Thank You Michelle for the work you do
and Aloha I've actually was in Florida
speaking at a teacher's conference last
year and I learned a lot about you know
all of us not Hawaiians know about the
term Aloha hellogoodbye but there's
there's this whole notion of Aloha
culture which is just like you know how
do you project love towards others and
that really touched me and so Aloha to
you as well another anonymous donation
$50 you know who you are thank you
Nashua to lobby on Facebook thank you
for your donation and Nashua Road thank
you for all your efforts I use Khan
Academy teach my three children you our
pride in hope well thank you so much
that that means a lot
keep up the great work a sour Holderman
thank you for your donation every dollar
matters and it means a ton to all of us
at Khan Academy that you're taking the
trouble to donate I know a lot of y'all
you know there's financial stress in the
world there's a lot of causes that need
help and they're all good noble causes
but I thank all of y'all for
appreciating that in this world right
now education is very very central and
it's and it's very the access to it is
very unequal and I think hopefully those
of you all are watching realize how
powerful a lever Khan Academy can be and
how much scale it has that you know as I
said we're the budget of a large high
school but we're able to reach a good
chunk of humanity and not just for this
year but for generations to come so you
know it's it's almost hard for the mind
to grasp but that's what gets us excited
and that's what gets us energized to do
the work that we need to do
so let's see we have another donation
just came on Facebook thank you so much
from anonymous you know who you are
maybe it's the same anonymous maybe it's
it's a different anon anonymous is I
guess so I see it looks like
unfortunately we're all out of time so I
will well actually I'll take I'll take
one more question because I think this
is very relevant from Facebook
Gary Wilmot asks how would you describe
the company culture at Khan Academy
how's Cove in nineteen did it well Gary
you know I'll tell you something that I
told the team we now have our company
meetings now as you can imagine on zoom'
and you know one thing that that the
leadership at Khan Academy has been
telling all the team members is this is
a time that you always have to take care
of yourself and your family before you
take care of others so you know we have
team members I mean myself included but
I'm lucky I have my wife and my
mother-in-law we're all in the same
house so we're able to tag-team with the
kids but there's we have team members
who might be a single parent they have
young children at home it's incredibly
hard and in a time like that the last
thing you need is for your employer to
say hey I thought that thing that you
are going to get done was going to get
done by this afternoon where is it so
we've made it very clear some of our
team members are able to step up they
maybe have a little more time and a lot
of us are getting pulled in a lot of
directions and so we're saying hey this
is not a time that we're judging you we
know that the people who are drawn to
this mission are drawn to do the right
thing and we want to figure out how we
can support you in any way shape or form
that we can and what I've told you know
I told this to the team at Khan Academy
yesterday so many times you know we have
these aspirations very ambitious
aspirations for what we can do in the
broader world you know let's educate a
billion people let's create an
institution so that parents teachers
students feel empowered for for for for
for hundreds of years to come
but in order for that to feel right for
the users we have to have the right
energy inside of our organization if
we're not energized if we're not
passionate about what we do that lack of
passion is going to be carried on to the
learners we shouldn't do anything unless
we genuinely care about it and so you
know I emphasize with our team members
work should not be work the way that a
lot of people think about it a lot of
people all
think about oh I got it's Monday morning
I guess I got to go to work I guess I
got to pay the bills work is where you
spend eight hours nine hours ten hours
or more per day for a good chunk of your
life it should be a place that fills
your soul it should be a place that
gives you meaning it should be a place
that makes you feel connected with other
people who are like-minded and you know
that's my aspiration for khanacademy
that not only can we be in some ways
pioneers on what could happen for the
world but we can also show examples of
organizations that believe in people
that are human that are about filling
your soul that you know aren't political
and all of the you know kind of notions
that you're not-- you might be used to
or you steer typical in some corporate
settings that can be a place where you
get the best out of people because every
human being has a natural desire to want
to help other people and a natural
desire to have impact on the world and
tackle challenging intellectual issues
and and I think you know that's what we
hope to do do it Khan Academy so the
culture I hope is you know I to be is
very collaborative I don't sense really
politics which I've sensed another it's
just that I've worked into my life
because I as I said people could go
other places if they wanted to optimize
for income or you know titles but people
are coming here to optimize for impact
and I think that just creates a really
really positive culture inside of an
organization so I will now read see
there's a last few folks who've donated
Neela us another anonymous donation on
YouTube $5.00 thank you as I said every
donation matters Aniela Mukerji local a
donated thing on Facebook thank you so
much Neela I really really appreciate
that and the time went by fast I guess
time by it goes by fast when you're I
guess maybe I'm talking too much and
there's a but I just want to say again
thank you so much for all of you who
donated in the past thank you so much
for all of you who donated now this
really makes a huge huge difference for
so many learners around the world and it
makes a huge difference for our team and
our capacity to do the work that we want
to do and this is especially true now
that we're in this kovat crisis and the
world needs things like Connick
me that much more so thank you being on
this journey with us tell everyone you
know that we exist we want to be used by
more people so that we can even we can
grow our impact even more and stay safe
stay healthy and I I will see you
tomorrow where we're going to have
actually Angela Duckworth famous
education researcher on things like grit
and resilience and perseverance and a
close friend of mine as well
on our homeroom livestream see you
tomorrow
hello Dean school closures I like to use
the schedule provided by Khan Academy's
my day includes doing the math lesson on
Khan Academy during my homework on
Google classroom and doing a guided
meditation on YouTube Thank You Khan
Academy
you